i'm brett baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday january 19 2022
i'm dave anthony secretary of state
anthony blinken is in ukraine to
reiterate american support amid growing
fears of a russian invasion if we cannot
guarantee something for ukraine and help
them to deal with this issue who else is
going to be thinking now well what is
our world wars
i'm lisa brady president biden holds a
news conference today to mark his first
year in office which isn't getting rave
reviews in the polls all of that has
changed but right now i think even the
most optimistic by backer recognizes
that he has dug himself into a hole we
speak with fox news's howard kurtz
i'm liz peake i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
is the russian bear about to claw
ukraine our view is this is an extremely
dangerous situation we are now at a
stage where russia could at any point
launch an attack in ukraine and today
secretary of state anthony blinken is
there talking to ukraine's president
what secretary blinken is going to go do
uh is highlight very clearly there is a
diplomatic path forward it is the choice
of president putin and the russians to
make whether they are going to suffer
severe economic consequences or not and
if russia does move in white house press
secretary jensaki says all options are
on the table in our view we continue
consulting closely with european
counterparts on severe counter
consequences for russia if it further
invades ukraine this blinking visit will
be followed by talks with some of our
allies in germany and then friday in
geneva the secretary of state will sit
down with his russian counterpart a
bipartisan group of u.s senators went to
ukraine before blinken including
democrat richard blumenthal who says if
russia invades we will give the people
of ukraine
the arms
lethal arms they need to defend
their lives this about eight years after
the fight for crimea russia took over
that disputed region from ukraine and
now has more than a hundred thousand
troops amassed near ukraine's border and
it's sending even more troops into
belarus for military exercises a u.s
state department official tells fox are
not normal and look ominous
unfortunately
president biden in his administration
does a lot of talk
but doesn't do
it doesn't work the walk congresswoman
victoria sparks is a republican from
indiana and as we'll get into later is a
ukrainian american who was born there
when it was part of the soviet union
it's not just you know they you know not
very good at domestic or international
policies they're also not a very good
card players and
unfortunately uh president putin is not
a bad card player and chess player and
he's taking advantage of the weaknesses
and the situation and really creates
instability in the eastern europe
president biden has warned over and over
and so has secretary of state blinken of
severe consequences harsh economic
sanctions if russia does invade ukraine
what has the administration done wrong
in your view in this game of chess or
cards as you as you likened it to
well i mean one thing this spring you
know they waived uh sanctions on north
stream too
and they got nothing for it you know
they you know say well we want to be
nice to europe and now they hope europe
is going to be nice to them i haven't
seen europe really trying to collaborate
with us very much so i think it was a
big mistake congresswoman let's go back
to nordstrom 2. this is a pipeline
correct and and what is it why is this
such an important issue
well it is an important issue because
this pipeline create dependency
of uh western europe on natural gas from
the countries like russia and what we
are doing here you know united states
could be one of the biggest and we still
are you know one of the biggest export
of uh liquid natural gas and we can help
europe to be less dependent on the
countries of russia you know instead of
that you know majority of our you know
liquid natural gas industry is idle
right now because we have
unrealistic and i would say stupid
energy policy right now and now empowers
russia to exercise even more power
because winter is coming and gas prices
are out of control right now in europe
and they're freezing instead of us
helping if we want to empower europe and
in having better capacity and continue
with president trump started to have
more experts in europe we generally
screwed europe with that and they moved
a lot of experts to asia and then you
know they now have to rely on russia
that is bad decision but now it's become
a problem
the troops
there are about a hundred thousand said
to be there on the border uh russia near
ukraine now russia is also
sending more troops to belarus for
military exercises with that country
belarus of course is also on the border
of ukraine does that make you even more
nervous
well i think it's unfortunate that
we know that president putin
decided to
align himself with very aggressive
countries with communist countries and
decided to instead of empowering his
country to become part of the developed
world with democracy and freedoms for
his people he decided to go back to
totalitarian regime and i think any
country from for the soviet union that
is free and democratic is a danger to
his own power because russians will
start thinking well you know what
ukrainians are free
polish people are free you know and we
are suppressed and at some point they
will start not liking it and become
bolder so he understand that he needs to
keep you know other countries around him
suppressed and a lot of people don't
realize that when soviet union fell
apart you know we actually signed you
know
ukraine was the third
largest nuclear power and had uh nuclear
uh weapons you know the third largest
after united states and russia so in
return for them giving up nuclear
weapons
we signed an agreement with russia and
uk
to reassure them that they have they'll
be a sovereign country and will not be
dividing the borders now it creates us a
problem because russia violated this
agreement if we cannot guarantee
something for ukraine and help them to
deal with this issue who else is going
to be thinking now well what is our
world wars what is our agreement worth
so it creates instability around the
world and we do not want to get into
nuclear proliferation it's very
dangerous for the world
russia is telling a very different story
denying it has any intention of invading
its neighbor instead it's demanding
guarantees from the us and nato that
ukraine and any other former soviet
state will never be allowed to join that
alliance and won't put troops or weapons
into those countries
nato leader yen stoltenberg says russia
doesn't get to dictate such decisions
allies are ready to support ukraine
on its path towards membership helping
to implement reforms modernize the armed
forces to meet nato standards
and then at the end of the day it has to
be nato allies and ukraine
that decides on membership congresswoman
spartz agrees
if ukrainian people want to do it and
nato decides that they are the members
that are ready to join then that should
be
decided by this parties no other country
you know should be um you know allowed
to say that you cannot do it you know if
russia would decide someday they want to
be a nato ally that should be up to the
russian people and later so i don't
think any country should be dictating
this rules but i think unfortunately
president putin got very emboldened and
he wants to again to instill his power
in europe and start dividing
on the camps and spheres of influence
europe which brings very unhealthy
environment to europe we've been through
it many times and it leads to
instability and wars in europe and i
think it's just a bad idea to start
going that direction but this is just a
bad negotiation right now and now we put
itself in situation that congress needs
to step up and put pressure on this
administration because they they their
actions create
bad policies and instability in europe
that you know will cause all the
headaches
this is very personal for you you are
the first ukrainian-american member of
congress you were born in ukraine back
when it was part of the soviet union
it's been a journey for you you came to
the united states so
i assume you still have family there
i do but i look at that more from a
standpoint you know i grew up when it
was soviet union you know and if you
think about it you know it was a
socialist country that failed for a
reason because social system failed in
the end and you can see how hard it is
to regain it back you know we have
ukraine been independent for 30 years
and they still try to fight for freedoms
i've seen a lot of
younger people like in our country get
inspired by some marxist ideas and
breaks my heart because a lot of
americans died for these freedoms and
for this a lot of people around the
world die to fight marxist communists
these are very destructive ideas and
they get embraced by some of the people
you know and i'm fine to have a debate
of ideas and everything else but it's
almost become an admiration in some of
the young people and it's sad for me to
see that after all of these fights and
so many lives lost in the last century
in the victory we just had not that long
time ago
we allow some of this
dictatorship and totalitarian views you
know to get back into power instead of
working and try to promote freedoms and
democracy further you know we see it now
in south america it's happening that is
a very disturbing to me we see how much
communist countries like china how much
power they're gaining you know and we're
not being proactive in having good
policy to promote liberty since the
ideas the things that empower people
that the things that make our country
the greatest in the world because that's
why you know we have the most freedom
that's why people want to come here do
you think people you grew up you lived
through oppression
and and communism do you think people
here just take what we have for granted
unfortunately people do especially
younger generation i think all the
generation went through a lot of
hardships and i think that is kind of
downfall of us as parents when you know
when our life is tough we want our life
of our children to be easier and then we
don't strengthen them enough don't build
enough resiliency in our children
because life is tough it's all about
overcoming adversary be able to deal
through problems and move forward and
never give up so you it's just you have
to teach you know it doesn't matter you
it doesn't matter which country you live
in you will deal with difficulties but i
think with the good intentions we made
our children weaker when they become
weaker they more become dependent on
government and i think that is something
is a strategic issue for our country we
don't fix education and if we don't
empower our children to be stronger to
pursue their happiness we're going to
have big problems in the country and we
have to as a policy maker stop like
doing bs and drama and talk about
nothing stupid things but really talk
seriously how we can strengthen our
people that we will be able to have
strong country because to have strong
country you have to have strong people
congresswoman victoria spartz republican
from indiana great to talk to you thank
you so much for joining us thank you
very much it's a pleasure
[Music]
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary coming up
tomorrow marks one year since president
biden took office appealing to a divided
nation to stop the shouting and lower
the temperature this is our historic
moment
of crisis and challenge
and unity is the path forward but that
path has had some detours and covid has
kept coming in waves now blamed for more
than 850 000 deaths in the u.s while
contributing to a wide range of economic
ripple effects the white house
spokeswoman jensaki says there is
progress for the president to talk about
as he holds a formal news conference
later today during the president's first
year we saw the most dramatic change in
our economy of anywhere in the world it
was the biggest year of job growth in
american history and it was the direct
result of actions taken by president
biden and democrats in congress
including the american rescue plan
republicans argue the economy was
already poised for recovery as pandemic
restrictions eased and that too much
government spending has helped fuel
inflation which has become a dominant
issue in recent polling while the
president's approval rating has fallen
down to a new low of 33 percent in a
quinnipiac poll
president biden's main goal at today's
news conference is pretty simple howard
kurtz is the host of media buzz on the
fox news channel and the media buzz
meter podcast
he has to reverse the narrative that has
spread throughout the mainstream media
that his first year has by and large
been a failure that he's on a
spectacular losing streak and he doesn't
have control of his own party and they
may not be up to the job then that's not
my opinion i'm seeing that by certain
people on msnbc new york times columnist
uh the press is really
reassessing joe biden right now after
his first year and the one thing that he
has to do in addition to talking to the
press boards we can discuss he's got to
change that storyline
when it comes to the press though i mean
some of the media were accused at first
at least of being too friendly to
president biden maybe that was an
assumption made um but as his problems
have deepened
have the media at large you know done a
better job holding his feet to the fire
so to speak or or have they turned on
him in some cases
i think for most of the year joe biden
operated in a pretty sympathetic media
environment certainly when you compare
it to the last president who got such
hostile treatment by and large from much
of the mainstream media and who gave it
back in return
biden came in and he was being compared
he was going to be fdr he's going to be
lbj this lasted for many months i think
on certain issues either bachelor in
afghanistan being the high on that list
problems at the mexican border and then
as time went on inflation supply chain
problems many in the press started to be
tougher on biden because he wasn't
delivering the results the omicron surge
is another example where the president
has very much been on the defensive but
i think by and large he's still not
getting hostile coverage i sense a kind
of uh exasperation or disappointment or
disillusionment in many of the certainly
left-leaning pundits who would like joe
biden to succeed but feel that he is
screwing up and that the people around
him are
making a lot of mistakes
there's certainly been some criticism of
the administration
from fellow democrats though
sometimes it sounds more just like
frustration
that things aren't getting done or that
more isn't getting done
quickly enough is he kind of battling
two
perceptions at once the public
perception and then also perceptions
within his own party
i think they're the same i think there's
a lot of frustration and disappointment
among democrats i think there's a lot of
frustration disappointment among the
public and i think that's shared
increasingly by the media because you
have these two big failures on two big
bills you know if biden had simply
declared victory after getting a bunch
of republicans to sign on to the
bipartisan infrastructure bill i think
he would be in much better shape yes he
would still have to deal with omicron he
would still have to deal with inflation
but instead uh having campaigned as a
kind of a moderate democrat who was not
going to sign on to the bernie agenda or
the aoc agenda he proceeded to push two
more bills first of course there was the
nearly two trillion dollar build back
better bill which had everything from
free pre-kindergarten to trial tax
credit to climate change and a bunch of
other things is like a liberal wish list
the miscalculation came in not realizing
that he was never going to get joe
manchin and kirsten sinema to sign on he
didn't have 50 democratic votes and so
that now appears to have failed then the
president decided to pivot to voting
rights by the time he did that and that
his delay disappointed many liberal
activists it was clear that the same two
democratic senators were not going to go
along with changing the filibuster which
would be required to pass it with 50
votes so he took on another issue where
he was destined to fail and in fact
appears to have failed despite the fact
that the senate has now been debating it
so when you put those two things against
the president's other problems i think
you have a portrait of a president who
to put it diplomatically is
underperforming
it was given that his poll numbers have
been sinking across the board i mean is
there
one issue that that's the worst issue
for him right now
if i had to single out one thing i'd say
inflation only because it touches
everybody it's an issue that a lot of
people inside the beltway you know
well-heeled journalists upper
middle-class politicians don't care that
much about if inflation is hit seven
percent but the average person trying to
buy groceries where there's a lot of
shortages lately due to supply problems
trying to buy gas for the car uh gets
really stung by that so i would i would
single that out but i think joe biden's
problems now as as some of my fellow
pundits are recognizing goes much deeper
i i think he is not coming across and
some of this is subjective but he's not
coming across as in command when you
can't convince the members of your own
party to back you on something that
essentially is the most important
remaining item in your agenda with
everybody knows this is a very strong
possibility republicans will take the
house this november then you don't come
across as being really strong and i
think he spends so much time in fact
there are stories coming out of the
white house now the new spin
saying that well he's going to reset
he's going to have a new communication
strategy it's always what you do you say
i'm getting bad pr
where he's gonna spend less time talking
to other lawmakers or at least making
that the focus and more time trying to
communicate directly with voters out in
the country i guess that makes sense but
i've argued for many months now that joe
biden doesn't make enough use of the
bully pulpit because the fact that he's
having this press conference today it's
only his tenth in office far fewer than
trump than obama than clinton and bush
also doesn't give very many one-on-one
interviews to the press he basically
avoids the press to the extent that he
can and that means he's not often
driving the news agenda i think that may
change given the fact that he's got the
sinking paul's numbers and he's got some
even people like maureen dowd of the new
york times and donnie deutsch and msnbc
starting to say hey he's not getting the
job done he doesn't appear
big enough for the job right now a lot
can change you know all the people who
say well of course they're all going to
get clobbered in november 75 things will
happen between now and then but right
now even the white house recognizes that
it's not doing well with the press and
it's not delivering the results
that many people had hoped to see from
joe biden
as you know though i mean here we are
now in the midterm election year i mean
does he even have
the possibility of making an effective
case on an issue any issue and actually
being able to gain any ground
during this news conference
a single news conference certainly is
not going to turn things around and
we'll see uh whether the reporters are
more confrontational with the president
than they have been i would think that a
series of news conferences if president
biden would hold more news conferences
would give his first interview uh as
president to the new york times to the
washington post to the wall street
journal to usa today would go on
television including fox news not just
with people who are deemed to be
friendly or podcast people who are
needing to be friendly or going on you
know late night comedy shows i think
over time he can make his voice heard
it's funny to say this about a president
or such a giant megaphone but basically
you know joe biden often is reacting to
events because he's not
moving the news agenda because he's not
saying anything other than bland
bromides on social media so i think
that's a
factor but the other factor is if the
economy were to continue to be strong if
uh the omicron surge fades and kovalen
is coming under more control uh then
people may feel more comfortable buying
this price in other words you know all
this stuff about pr and dealing with the
press it's all very nice but you got to
deliver results right now it feels like
the biden administration is kind of
flailing and doesn't have its footing uh
then there's problems dealing with the
russians and other things on the foreign
agenda as well
all of that could change but right now i
think even the most optimistic by backer
recognizes that he has dug himself into
a hole
what about the optics
for
today's event i mean if for instance the
white house
doesn't allow enough questions or is
perceived to not allow enough questions
it tries to keep it very short
how damaging could that be or does that
not even matter at this point
i think it would be a mistake and i
don't expect this to happen for
president biden to take just a handful
of questions and then walk off all
reporters are still shouting since he
holds so few news conferences and of
course most people won't see it live
they'll see the clips and that's how
they'll form their judgments um he ought
to take a whole bunch of questions he
actually you know
the conventional wisdom is biden doesn't
talk to reporters more because his team
and maybe the president himself he once
called himself a gaff machine thinks he
may misstep he may say something that he
regrets he might snap at a reporter he's
been known to do that on occasion when
he's pressed particularly do you have
confidence in such and such an issue i
think that's a risk worth taking for the
president to
grab the headlines
be all over television not just tonight
but in the days to come
and if he holds more news conferences
talks to more reporters does more
interviews what if he even went on a
sunday show or two
i think then each particular malopropism
or misstep it matters less because
people are more used to seeing them when
you have very few press events then each
one gets this big build up and it
becomes harder to completely
avoid any problems so biden's got his
work cut out for him and i think look
when you're riding high in the polls and
people you're generally popular then you
can stiff the press and probably not pay
much for a price right now that's not
where president biden is
what is
the number one thing
you think he should not do during this
news conference
uh say that's a really stupid question
to a reporter uh there's a couple of
times the incidents are pretty well
known now once uh where he snapped at
cnn's caitlyn collins and said if you
don't understand that you shouldn't even
be in the business okay that's not a
good look uh people like joe biden and
they generally have liked him over the
years he's been around obviously for
many decades because he's a genial guy
because he uh connects with people
particularly working class people and if
he's seen as churlish or snapping out
reporters i mean that's that's the trump
style he doesn't want to go down that
road he should answer the questions
hopefully his team has supplied him with
good answers but ultimately the public
will be the judge of that you know he
doesn't have to please the press uh
we're just one element but certainly
we're a key part of any white house
communication strategy
howard kurtz host of media buzz and the
media buzz meter podcast thank you so
much for your time
good to talk to you
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
raiden review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
liz peak
what's on your mind one year into his
presidency president biden is
floundering and his party is divided
unusually polling shows voters would
prefer republicans control both the
house and the senate
the stage is set
oddsmakers give the gop a 70 chance of
taking back control of the house and the
senate up from 32 percent in july
those odds lengthen if republicans can
unify behind a powerful common-sense
platform that gives americans what they
want
joe biden and other democrats have
totally abandoned the middle road
embracing far-left policies on issues
ranging from the economy to crime they
have given the gop a dramatic opening to
take advantage of that opening here's
what republicans should offer number one
get america working again
more than three million fewer workers
are on the job today than in february
twenty twenty
a critical labor shortage is one of the
key drivers of inflation common sense
means we must encourage work drop the
vaccine mandates that have kept truckers
off the road and nurses out of hospitals
also republicans must insist that relief
and welfare payments go to the needy and
prohibit more large-scale payouts that
have kept workers on the sidelines
two make our streets safe again demand a
return to common sense policing and an
end to dangerous bail and enforcement
policies that let hardened repeat
criminals out of jail
three enforce our immigration laws stop
the surge of people entering the country
illegally by taking away the rewards of
breaking our laws
toughen our border reduce the benefits
and work opportunities available to
people who are undocumented and embrace
the remain in mexico policy
at the same time grant dreamers legal
status as resident legal aliens and a
path to citizenship
solve this running soar
four give parents a choice in their
children's schools
establish standards for our schools that
guarantee opportunity for all and demand
that failing schools be closed or
reformed
common sense means curtailing the power
of the teachers unions that oppose
accountability by making school choice a
reality for all americans
five restore energy independence return
to an all-of-the-above energy policy
that safeguards the needs of americans
and preserves a critical geopolitical
advantage
six protect small businesses
keep taxes low and reduce the red tape
burden on all americans and especially
on small firms that are the backbone of
our economy and our cities
this is not rocket science finding
common good paying attention to the
concerns of voters and attracting
compromise is not magic it takes hard
work and requires solid arguments
moreover it takes common sense
joe biden was elected mainly because he
wasn't donald trump and also because he
promised to govern as a moderate and to
bring the country together
during his first year in office biden
has utterly betrayed the trust of
america's voters and deserves his own
shellacking come november
branding themselves as the party of
common sense republicans stand an
excellent chance of delivering just that
this is liz peek fox news contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes